at five a hunt for a good cause various
parks across clark county were filled
with tons of easter eggs today mary jane
belliesa takes us to desert horizons and
shares how one organization is raising
awareness on foster care
[Music]
dozens came out saturday morning in
support for saffie's easter egg hunt
safi which stands for specialized
alternatives for families and youth
provide therapeutic care to foster kids
in the system who need mental health
support kaitlyn johnson with safi says
this event is all about raising
awareness for that cause we decided that
we were going to hide one egg for every
child and teen that's been impacted by
foster care in clark county over the
last decade so that totaled 60 thousand
easter eggs
and then we also really wanted to drive
home the point of our kids are from all
over clark county so we chose 30 parks
all over clark county each egg contains
a qr code when scan provides you more
information on the organization how to
volunteer and donate and much more
jennifer chassero along with her two
kids say the egg hunt highlights an
important issue all while having fun at
the same time it means a lot to us
because actually wendell and jack bulls
got donations to um stuff the eggs and
they did a little drive
and so we
volunteered to
stuff the eggs and we actually went out
and hid all the eggs this morning and so
it was nice to see them
do
do something good for the community if
you weren't able to come out to the
event johnson says there are still
plenty of ways to support our foster
youth whether that's providing donations
monetary or items or volunteering at
things like this we always have
volunteer opportunities available on our
website so you can check that out at
sapphy.org
and then we also you can become a foster
parent or a respite parent mary jane
vallieza live local now
johnson says with an amazing turnout at
today's event across clark county they
anticipate to hold this event again next
year